we're told that Penny wrote a survey
with open-ended and multiple choice
questions the diagram shows the ratio of
the question types so what it shows us
is that for every one two three four
five open-ended questions there are one
two three four multiple choice questions
and let's be clear this is showing the
ratio of open-ended questions to
multiple choice questions it's not
telling us exactly how many of each type
of question we have we just know for
every five open-ended therefore multiple
choice or for every four multiple choice
there are five open-ended
the table shows some numbers of multiple
choice questions and total questions
that could be on Penny survey based on
the ratio complete the missing values in
the table
so like always pause this video and see
if you can have a go at this on your own
before we work through it together
alright so some of you might not have
realized that it says total questions
here it does not say multiple choice
questions and open-ended questions
so one way to tackle this is to think
about well what is going to be the ratio
between multiple choice questions and
total questions so let's think if we
were to create another bar for total
questions that showed the ratio for
every five open-ended questions you'll
have four multiple choice questions and
you would have nine total questions so
it would look like this one two three
four five six seven eight and nine I'm
just adding these two together
so we could say that the ratio of
multiple choice to Total questions is
going to be 4 to 9 for every four
multiple choice questions you're going
to have nine total questions
so in this first row we have eight
multiple choice questions so that's two
sets of four
so we're going to have two sets of nine
total questions
that still is the same ratio 8 is to 18
as 4 is to 9.
and now in the second row they give us
the actual number of total questions
well that is 9 goes into 45 five times
that's five sets of nine so you're going
to have five sets of four multiple
choice questions so five times four is
twenty and we're done